movies have to be particularly careful
when it comes to adding controversial
scenes since everything's right there on
the screen there isn't much left of the
imagination books on the other hand can
get away with a lot more which is why
adapting a book to film can be tricky
business
so which film adaptations left the most
controversial scenes on the cutting room
floor let's take a look it chapter 1
easily the most controversial scene in
Stephen King's 1986 novel it takes place
after the losers Club defeats the evil
entity in the sewers when they get lost
on the way out the group's only female
Beverly comes up with a strange plan to
help unite the group she'll get busy
with them all one by one immediately
afterward one of the boys remembers how
to escape the sewer system
unsurprisingly
the scene was entirely dropped for both
the 2017 film and the 1990 miniseries
screenwriter Gary Doberman told
Entertainment Weekly while it's an
important scene it doesn't define the
book in any way we know what the intent
was of that scene and why he put it in
there and we tried to accomplish what
the intent was in a different way me
before you the romance film me before
you had the benefit of being adapted for
the big screen by the novel's author
herself Jojo Moyes which only makes it
more interesting that the film lacks one
rather critical plot point in the movie
the female protagonist Louisa Lu Clarke
is quirky and intelligent which is why
nobody really understands what keeps her
from spreading her wings in the book
however we learn exactly what Lu's Deol
is in high school she was assaulted
something she keeps firmly under wraps
this critical plot point is used to
explain pretty much everything about Lu
from her weird and overtly conservative
sense of style to her offbeat
personality Moyes claimed they tried to
put that scene into the movie but it
simply didn't fit saying I worked with
the director a long time writing this
scene and trying different variations of
it it achieves a different weight when
you do that in pictorial form the more
we tried the more we realized it just
skewed the tone of the whole thing it
was changing the mood of the story the
road Cormac McCarthy's 2006 Pulitzer
winning novel the road and it's 2009
film adaptation tell the story of a
father and sons fight for survival in a
post-apocalyptic wasteland where nearly
all organic life has died the film has
its fair share of heavy moments but
one particularly disturbing scene was
left by the roadside in the book the
pair encounters a group of survivors
about to eat a baby a scene which was
filmed but ultimately discarded director
John Hill code explained it all works in
the book because it's in your head when
you visualize some of this stuff it just
becomes too much
we'd have to agree with him on that
Paper Towns adapted from John Green's
young adult novel of the same name
2015's mystery dramedy Paper Towns tells
a coming-of-age story about an all-night
roadtrip of revenge however one
particular scene from the book was
intentionally left out of the film in
the book the two main characters Quentin
and Margo break into SeaWorld at the end
of the night however following the
release of the documentary blackfish
which shone a light on what happens to
whales in captivity the screenwriters
decided to drop the SeaWorld part
completely and have the characters in
their night at Orlando's SunTrust
building instead producer Wyck Godfrey
explained the change saying since John
wrote the book the documentary blackfish
came out I think it's a little less
playful to go to SeaWorld now divergent
in order to maintain a financially
friendly pg-13 rating the film
adaptation of Veronica Roth's
post-apocalyptic why a novel divergent
had to be toned down in the major way
but one particularly graphic scene from
the book was cut for different reasons
altogether in the scene the dauntless
initiate played by bin lamb wakes up
with a knife in his eyeball director
Neil burger explained that he'd shot the
scene but then decided to leave it out
of the theatrical release because it was
interrupting the flow of the story he
told cinema blend even though it's a
good scene that's really the art of
trying to figure out where the movie is
working and sometimes what's slowing it
down is one of your favorite scenes
you've got to cut it out Gone with the
Wind you can't talk about the history of
American cinema without mentioning Gone
with the Wind adapting the racially
charged novel for the big screen however
was no easy feat as the Atlantic points
out in the book the central black
characters are content with slavery
uninterested in freedom author Margaret
Mitchell once describes a character is
having the uncommon worse the book calls
the Ku Klux Klan a quote tragic
necessity obviously to produce
had a hard time remaining faithful to
the original story even for the 1930s
some of these scenes were a little too
racist American Psycho Mary herons film
adaptation of Bret Easton Ellis's 1991
bestseller American Psycho doesn't shy
away from disturbing scenes we watched
the film's protagonist Patrick Bateman
brutally dispatched multiple people and
Phillip a colleague's apartment with
bodies still the film doesn't even touch
some of the scenes from the book which
is so disturbing that the New York Times
said it was understandable when Simon
and Schuster refused to publish it it's
a pretty messed-up stuff and harun
probably made the right choice when she
decided to keep most of the brutality
off the screen including one horrible
chainsaw scene on the plus side at least
we got to see Christian Bale's
moonwalking Huey Lewis monologue he's
been compared to Elvis Costello but I
think Huey has a far more bitter cynical
sense of humor thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel let's check out all this
cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]